well for survivors and victims families
of a 2012 sandy hook massacre in
connecticut the attack at the rob
elementary school in texas
brings up chilling reminders of a very
dark day in american history scarlett
louis's son jesse was just six years old
when he was killed along with 19 other
students and six adults and scarlett
joins me now scholar thank you so much
for joining me i i thought of all of you
because i was on air at the time in
america at cnm when this happened uh it
was an absolutely harrowing story
to report on as indeed had been the
similar massacre at dunblane in scotland
in the mid-90s
and in fact this morning i had an email
exchange with one of the mothers of one
of the children who died at dunblane
because
i recognize that for all of you
trapped in this appalling club of
mothers and fathers who've lost kids to
these school massacres
when another one happens it must take
you all right back
to the day that you lost your own
children is that what it was like for
you when you heard about this
absolutely pierce i i i was living the
experience right alongside all of those
parents when they were waiting to get
word whether their child was going to be
found dead or alive those hours those
torturous hours
and then you know
my first thought this morning was
how they would wake up and and for one
split second forget and then this
crushing blow would come down over them
that
their child was dead that yesterday they
were planning
uh the summer fun and and today they're
going to have to start thinking about
writing an obituary they're going to
have to start planning for funerals and
it is
it was a gut punch to me and and so
incredibly painful and and honestly i
can't believe that i'm
standing here talking to you ten years
after the murder of my own son jesse at
sandy hook alongside 19 of his first
grade classmates and six educators and
now here we have another one after
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
school shootings later and of course
columbine 20 years before and we are
still hearing the same tired narrative
it is so frustrating
you know there's the saying that the the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing again and again and expecting a
different result you could switch this
round and say that with these massacres
in america and the school shootings the
definition of insanity is doing nothing
again again and again and expecting a
different result you know i knew after
sandy hook that if there was no change
at all
in the way that america was going to
respond to these massacres then
inevitably there would be more of them
i i felt the same way piers i i i saw
some movement but
we're always a step behind and the
frustrating thing is
these are preventable every single one
and we're reactive and as you said we do
the same thing over and over expecting a
different result it's the definition of
crazy that's why
after jesse's murder
obama flew in he was talking about gun
control and i realized that that had
failed
obviously for sandy hook and so i took a
different approach i decided to focus on
the root cause of the pain and suffering
that leads to these events and so in
other words offering
schools homes and communities skills and
tools that they can use that help kids
face their hurt and pain be able to
manage it uh live with it grow through
it be strengthened by it and flourish i
think that this is absolutely a hundred
percent necessary it should be in every
single school
uh and and and i'm actually on my choose
love bus tour right now you caught me in
new hampshire
working for governor sununu traveling
around the state
bringing love hope and healing to
communities here that we've been doing
through
through the
pandemic and we will continue to do you
do remarkable work and it's very
inspiring that out of such an appalling
tragedy you're able to find the strength
to do this and i commend you for that i
want to take you back to what happened
to your boy he was six years old and he
was an absolute little hero because he
was in the classroom when the
the shooter adam lanza came in and his
gun jammed
and your little lad jesse shouted at his
friends to get out of the classroom
which a large number of them did i think
eight or nine of the kids got out and
then he was shot dead
uh absolute hero was that in keeping
with his character
absolutely absolutely that was jessie
and i i if he wasn't coming back as we
waited for those hours i knew that he
would have done something brave and when
the the shooter had shot his way through
the glass doors of sandy hook elementary
school he made a left
down the first grade hallway of course
he knew where that was because he had
attended that school
the principal and guidance counselor
were meeting with a parent they were
startled they opened the door to see
what
what the the the noise was all about
they were gunned down and then the
shooter turned into jesse's first grade
classroom everyone was scattered his gun
actually ran out of bullets at that time
and during the short delay that it took
him to change his clip
jesse called for his classmates to run
and he is credited with saving nine of
his classmates lives before losing his
own
no child should ever be asked to do that
in his in school i mean it is our
responsibility to keep our kids
safe and to address their mental health
and well-being and we have to start
taking that responsibility a lot more
seriously in fact we need to start
making our kids a priority
yeah i mean it just seems to me that one
of the worst things about the
these
massacres certainly the last two and
sandy hook is the age of the people
doing this and there seems to be a
pattern of sort of disenfranchised young
kids 18 19 20
disconnected from society
who uh i think this one had was addicted
to video games and so on which
i think also was the one at sandy hook
um but what strikes me is completely
perplexing i think it does to many
people uh in america as well as outside
is that they none of them could have
bought a beer legally in any of the
states that they were living they
couldn't buy a kinder surprise chocolate
egg
but they can go and buy a semi-automatic
rifle
and this is what they do legally i mean
the last two massacres were committed by
18 year olds who bought guns perfectly
legally but they couldn't get a beer if
they wanted to it seems incomprehensible
to me that you would have a set of laws
where you can't get a beer but you can
buy a semi-automatic gun and go and
shoot up a school
actually what's really interesting to me
is that the brain
doesn't uh fully develop until you're
25.
so uh it it becomes very frustrating and
it is appears it's the same story over
and over and over again it is bullying
it's disconnection it's isolation it's
loneliness it's a focus on on activities
that are singular
and it is a lot
of hurt and pain and suffering and it's
kids that do not have social and
emotional competence they do not have
coping mechanisms they don't have the
ability to manage that pain so it
continues to grow into rage and all they
know to do because they don't know that
they have a choice is to take that pain
out on other people and
each and every one could be preventable
with
literally
what we're doing now that is why i am on
the road and i want to tell you too that
i i have hope uh i was addressing a high
school today there were 400 kids this
was a speak up event that was organized
in new hampshire our strongest state for
choose love because of governor sununu
understanding that this is a really
important piece for school safety
and the kids knew that they needed help
they wanted to address their mental
health and so they literally uh
created this idea and created the entire
day
their their educators and administration
got on board and supported them and so
we talked about what was going on in in
a teenager's life today there's so much
i mean we have we have these cell phones
and we've got 24 7 information that
adults really can't handle that our
brains haven't caught up to we have
front row tickets to the worst of
humanity and we're not giving our kids
the skills and tools that they need to
manage that trauma that's literally
sitting in their hand and so today i
shared with them some really
life-transforming and life-saving skills
that will help them manage their pain
not just today but throughout their life
and we know through science is a pathway
to flourishing we need to do more of
this pierce scarlet i could not agree
with you more i think it's i think the
desensitization of this generation of
kids is a massive problem i think it's
driven by endless exposure to shocking
imagery and videos and so on from social
media shared around you know they're
seeing stuff in real time happening
minutes after it happens whereas 40
years ago you would never have seen it
and i think it's a it's a massive
problem i'm i'm awestruck by your
courage and your inspiration to be
perfectly honest you know i remember
sandy hook so vividly you know maybe
upset just remembering it as i thought
about your boy and all the others um so
thank you for what you're doing because
we've got to try and work our way
through this and there's not a simple
solution but there's going to be there's
got to be a solution i'll i'll leave
i agree and i'll leave you with this
jesse left a message on our kitchen
chalkboard shortly before he went to
school and then later was murdered he
wrote three words nurturing healing love
now they were phonetically spelled
because he was in first grade and just
learning to write but i knew then and
there that if the shooter had been able
to give and receive
nurturing healing love the tragedy would
never have happened we know that someone
who loves and feels good about
themselves they're not going to want to
hurt themselves and they're not going to
want to hurt other people so that really
gave me my mission jesse gave me my
mission he uh he and his big brother jt
are examples for me for courage and so
i'm going to keep going because i truly
believe in my heart that this is the
solution and that we can reduce and
prevent the majority of suffering that
we're experiencing in our country and in
our world by choosing love yeah scarlet
i
couldn't put it better than you because
i can't put it better than you you've
just put it as well as it could be
expressed and i just want to end by
saying again how heroic your lad jesse
was that day he saved the lives of
so many of his little classmates and it
cost him his life but what an amazing
little hero he was and i wish you all
the very best with your campaigning keep
it up
thank you thanks pierce
they're remarkable people and they
belong to
the worst club you could ever be in
isn't it the club of the
parents who've
never seen their children again because
they got gunned to pieces at school in
these massacres
you